Hey everyone, and welcome to my Death Note Teaser Breakdown.
Now it's easy to assume that every live
action anime adaptation is gonna suck.
But what's important is that we keep an open mind and-
Oh, shit. This doesn't look good. Oh, god sucks starting already. Oh, it's getting worse.
NO! IT SUCKS SO MUCH!!!
IT'S JUST THE FIRST FUCKING FRAME AND IT'S SUCKS SO MUCH!!!
OH GOD, THEY RUINED!!!
Alright, what is is this and who decided to make Light looks like a cross between
Milo Yiannopoulos, Emo Maguire and Max Landis,
walking out of the late 2000s Panic At The Disco Album.
It's this what fucking happens when someones writes Death Note in Death Note?
Now a lot of people have been complaining that there are cheerleaders here
and I don't see what the problem is.
I mean, if this was set in a highschool
then they're finally understanding the first step to properly adapting a fuckin anime.
Alright, you see this scene here,
WAY too fucking basic.
Obviously they've missed the entire point of Death Note,
But here, it's an easy fix let me do that for you.
*ting*
There we go. Fuckin perfect.
Oh my fucking god.
What i- What is this?
They made an official Twitter account for Ryuk.
Some company actually paid money for this to happen?
Alright, I don't care what anyone says. This hilarious and fucking brilliant
but if they used it properly.
Not for this shitty promos we see here.
I wanna see tweets like this.
"Did you know
Shinigami's Love apple?"
"But not Granny Smiths those are for basic bitches.
Pink Ladies all the way.
Fuji's alright too but way too expensive."
"#TescoSortYourSelectionOutM8"
Speaking of Ryuk, at least we can all agree that Ryuk's seems to be the thing that's done right.
I mean, I'm not sure if there's any concept shots of an images yet.
Oh God, he looks terrifying. They did an amazing job.
Oh man, imagine waking up to this.
THIS IS HOW DEATH GOD SHOULD-
Oh wait, it's just William Dafoe.
"Got bored again and ended up starting another social purging by giving this kid a Death Note."
"Why does this happen every time I drink on Saturday night LOL."
Hmmmm. I not sure I've covered everything I need to cover here.
Wait, here we go.
What is this Dragon Note
Evolution
The Last
Air Bender?
*laughs*
Alright, yeah yeah, that- that will do.
And the next thing is...
Oh alright yeah, definitely, I got this one.
*clear throat*
WHAT THE HELL IS UP WITH THIS BLATANT IN WHITE WASHING?
WHY CAN'T WE JUST HAVE A DEATH NOTE FILM
WITH JAPANESE ACTORS
SET IN JAPAN
WHERE THEY ARE SPEAK IN JAPANESE?
LIGHT YAGAMI?
MORE LIKE WHITE YAGAMI!
WHY ARE THEY SPEAKING ENGLISH
IN AN ENGLISH ADAPTATION?
THIS IS RUDE
AND OFFENSIVE,
AND DISRESPECTFUL TO THE JAPANESE CULTURE.
Good job at casting a black L though.
Look, if you're going to Americanize it and change
Light Yagami to Light Turner.
Don't pushed it to do half-heartedly,
if you doing this commit all the fucking way.
Death God Ryuk? Nope.
I wanna see Death God Ryan.
Justice for Kira?
Please. This justice for Kieran.
Alright, I think that's everything I can say about what's been really-
Wait a minute!
I've just been informed that we have exclusive footage that's just been leeched right now
of one scene of the upcoming movie.
Please be aware that this could contain major spoilers to Death Note
and the upcoming movies.
So watch this at your own peril.
Roll Clip.
[ Death Note Music Playing ]
Okay, serious talk time here.
Let's just all calm down for a second, all right.
Are we calm?
We calm. Good.
It's 50 fucking second long teaser
and that WAY too little to make any sort of solid judgements about the overall quality of this thing,
whether that be good or bad.
For all the negative attitude surrounding this teaser,
the only thing I've really had the problem with was indeed Lights look.
And it's not because he's white.
It's seems to replaced Light for this kind of kid,
who looks he would have watched Death Note way back when.
Not starring in it.
Which go against his suave handsome poster child look
his character is origin all known for.
But then again, Light is supposed to be a piece of shit of a guy
and he definitely looks like it, so maybe that's what they're going for.
L being black doesn't bother me at all,
as long as he can keep the quirkiness of the original character.
Having said that even then, we don't know much about these characters are being handled
and how they fit in to the overall story of whatever they decided to adapt.
There's really very little context to judge these so called bad scene.
Lights kissing someone.
Well he also did, so in the anime as a means of manipulation.
He's running and there are big set pieces.
Well honestly, if they're able to keep the psychological thriller aspect
and cat and mouse game absorbing,
who really cares if there are some set pieces.
One of the reason the anime worked
was because the animation and direction was able to make much mundane scenes more dynamic and exciting.
Which is part the reason, why the live-action version felt so fucking flat,
because it couldn't do that.
But even if we're going down this route and judging from some basic
cinematography shot composition and design,
it set a better atmosphere tone and looks way better to technically
than anything produced by the Japanese live action film.
There are competent filmmakers behind this
with the talented horrid director,
so you don't have to be so quick to jump on the hate bandwagon.
and I mean William Dafoe is Ryuk?
Grade A casting.
I just hope to get Ryuk's look to looks as terrifying as the photos.
and no, changing aspects like names or location
to fit a western adaptation is neither a sign that it's bad nor disrespectful.
And there is already a Japanese adaptation,
so I'd be far more disappointed, if they just kept every thing the same with no thought.
We understand that things need to be changed for Western adaptations of foreign films
so why don't we put anime up on this pedestal
like it is untouchable, unchangeable work of God.
Most of all though, I am just tired of the white washing debate and it frustrates me
that it looks like it's going to become a fucking trend
that whenever an anime get some adaptation,
the topic of racial casting will get more attention that either the adaptation  or the original anime in question.
And I have neither the patience nor the energy to get in this debate once again,
as I already done so.
But I will say, if you're angry about the casting choices at least keep it consistent.
I've seen way more people angry about Light's being white and L being black,
which is kind of hypocritical. Look, if this is really about respecting the original Japanese culture
then either both road are okay or neither of them are.
If you want more in depth reason as why none of the changes matter right now,
I've already made a video why sometimes it's best if an adaptation shouldn't stay faithful to the original.
And also what about judging an adaptation by it's own  fucking merits,
so can we all agree whether this film be worth watching or not.
If there is no potato chip scene...
we will fucking riot.
[ Music Play ]